it's a great pleasure to in today's day
who's gonna who's with us from the
there's a the usual joke here is the
school across the bay or the farm or
yeah all these little insulting ways to
talk about stuff I will tell you my joke
which is what's the difference between
Stanford and Persian
so if you do myself
Stanford is clean safe and boring
Berkeley is the opposite
but we are very welcome to our Stanford
friends because some of our faculty also
came from Stanford
thank you
hello everyone
um thank you for being here uh I know
it's late afternoon and I know you are
here to listen to my talk or Scott talk
uh thank you for that MD
um I want to first ask a question how is
the workshop so far for you
okay great great great so the workshop
is on large language models apparently
I'm not going to talk about it today uh
what I'm going to focus on is to share
my thoughts on people and the real world
uses I think you're done already opened
this up by seeing that the next phase of
natural language process and maybe more
real world problems so hopefully I can
share some thoughts here
um a lot of issues yesterday Nicholas
was also talking about attack and risk
for me I kind of approach it from a
social Dopeman
um this is earlier this year
um I'm sure if you uh can imagine that
uh questions like this will get uh
dodged by large language models because
it's not a good action
and at that time instead of doing very
automatic uh optimized way of making the
field we were thinking about what would
be some different reasoning structures
for social or controversial scenarios so
a simple phrase like think step by step
is going to give you all the potential
drama of a lot of questions we actually
have a lot of cool examples in the paper
and apparently this is not working today
so you do not need to give it a try
um other things I want to mention is
that we have been talking about a lot of
progress in NLP but apparently there are
also a rising issues reported with those
models
um I do not need to remind you again but
just reading those news headlines we can
see that the models seem to still have
troubles in dealing with issues such as
culture hated speech biases and those
issues really hinder the Practical
adoption of large language models in the
real world
so
another thing I want to mention is that
this is not only just about
um biases if you think about the value
which is a very high level social
construct apparently if you use models
trender let's say on a western Centric
coppers for protruding alignment Etc the
values may get alerted to reflect the
U.S culture if you apply it to a
slightly different document or different
region so apparently a lot of issues
seem to merge from the people side
uh well I think about a lot of the
specific phenomena we see so far around
all sorts of instance we can imagine
around the low resource language buyers
fairness hated speech harms limited
social understanding the generalized
issue are actually about our models do
not have a good understanding or
awareness of interrupting groups culture
ideology Norms social norms Common Sense
com social contacts Etc
and then taking all together the common
theme I think is the human factor here
human factor is underrated today because
it's not like a math function you can
optimize it's really hard to
operationalize it's really hard to
capture however it's very essential and
unnecessary to be well studied to push
either large language model or LLP to
the next level
so I was wondering whether we could have
a different
um view towards this space so people
this is the term I'm going to introduce
today from large language models in the
past few days we have been looking at
the research around the reasoning
benchmarking robustness verification
grounding interpretability on the people
side there are also a lot of very
exciting questions that we can take a
look at there are social factors there
are culture Norm value fairness privacy
interaction trust and impact all of them
seem very important we all agree but how
should we get started there
so my research view or my action for the
next step is that we need to think about
when people are interacting with large
language models how should we approach
from there and move forward from there
and then specifically very selfishly
related to my own research there are
three keywords I want to kind of
emphasize and then I'll give a very
quick highlights um highlight of case
studies to support each of them so
socially aware human centered and
positively impactful what does that mean
when I think about the space of large
language models or NLP I think there has
been a long-standing focus towards
mainstream populations but we think
about human people there are speakers
who do not speak mainstream languages
there are law resource languages
dialogues that exist in almost every
corner of U.S and also the world there
are vulnerable populations who probably
need assistance in terms of language
understanding and a lot of other
applications
in terms of cultural ideology it comes
to the question of whose culture and
value are represented in this process
norm and context is going to affect how
we understand the specific sentence
especially when it comes to interaction
with large language models
so uh in other to kind of formulate this
space my colleague and I we kind of
introduced this very uh practical and
the simple framework to think about how
or what type of social factors are
involved when we use language to
interact or to communicate so when you
think about speaker who is a receiver
what's their social relation in what a
context uh get it by what type of social
Norm cultural ideology and for what type
of community go here
the other thing I want to kind of
emphasize today is that we already see a
lot of amazing applications you can
perform use NLP systems AI systems large
language models
um I'm advocating for more
human-centered design thinking into this
process in terms of how we can
incorporate domain users and
stakeholders into different stages of
large language model research if you
think about problem formulation data
collection model training evaluation and
deployment
especially with the recent emergence of
AI agents I also feel we need this kind
of mixed initiative interaction not only
human in the loop but also how human can
benefit from machine assistance and a
lot of cool stuff we can work on in
terms of human AI interaction for better
coordination collaboration that is how
we can leverage the intelligence from
both parties
uh last but not least the last keyword I
want to share today is that uh there are
a lot of objectives in the community
that we can take we used to think that
accuracy performance is the main
Direction there is a single number that
we are all chasing for here I want to
mention that there are a lot of other
objectives we need to think about not
just focus on performance if you think
about a large language model and the
people interaction there are lots of
social beneficial applications and
knowledge domains like policy mental
health education a lot of those not only
we just use them as a tool in this
process we are going to produce
knowledge insights and also
translational impact from uh human AI
interaction and the other dimension is
that there are also a lot of influence
of large language model on people and we
see not much or I guess not a lot of
research in this direction the think
about misinformation think about the
allocation harms how large language
model could boost product productivity
how it might affect trust and how it may
even influence the creativity of our
human beings as a whole
so that's a very high level abstract
introduction I want to use three case
studies to go through what I mean by
those like a very fuzzy and high level
constructs
um first I'm going to talk about the
whole large language model work when it
comes to social contacts and the second
is that I want to make large language
models understand different type of
englishes so they already understand
English what do I mean by various
englishes here and then third which is a
very exciting part that I won't really
want to get to today if I have the time
is about how we could actually build
multi-agent systems powered by large
language model for social skill training
such as negotiation conflict resolution
positive thinking
any questions so far
great
um so first when large language model
meets social contacts why I was thinking
this way
well um again I come from a traditional
NLP training background I also get a lot
of training in HCI when I think about
these problems there are actually two
split a world in front of us sometimes
um when we think about large language
models we need to go beyond accuracy if
you look at the left aspects there are
accuracy performance efficiency
scalability a lot of terms we can lead
to but then on the other side if we
think about interaction there are
usability engagement in action human
factors as I mentioned earlier
is this an easy adaption process
the answer is no there are a lot of
instant data we need to make it adaptive
to users and contacts we need
explanation who to hold accountable for
errors and also a lot of unpredictable
model behaviors that we probably don't
see in our validation process
on the other direction if we think about
this is just application question why
don't you just build a model for it and
solve it the reality is more difficult
than that it's really hard to articulate
what can be done what cannot be done if
you think about the technical
feasibility we always make a lot of
assumptions towards okay here is a
gaussian distribution here is a uniform
distribution Etc real world probably
doesn't work in that way uh there are
also prototype Challenge and a lot of
open feedback that we don't know how to
put into our math equation
so we kind of uh want to approach it
from a relative comprehensive view what
I mentioned about social contacts so
earlier this year we were thinking about
what if we provided a lens or evaluation
framework for this type of models in
Social context
and the social context is another very
big word in most cases we call it social
media or we cut other type of things
here we want to make it more grounded in
our science field so we take a look at
the psychology political science
literature history sociology linguistics
and then what we do is that we're going
to get all the well-studied or very
represented the tasks in each field and
then use them as a test bed to see how
current models are doing for these
different dimensions as you can see we
have emotion recognition humor
recognition platinous empathy ideology
detection
agenda setting framing power relation
social role data features a lot of those
this is not our Focus if you look at the
a benchmark
um so for each of them we kind of gather
resources we have from the community
there are already a lot of such
resources available and you can see that
those tasks are not as simple they are
not simply just a sentence
classification some of them may involve
patterns conversation some of them may
involve a lot of like document level
understanding
and when you have such a rich context
you can ask many many many research
questions beyond the skill law Beyond
The Domain utility beyond the
functionality I'm just going to mention
maybe one or two of them today
so what it turns out that is that we
need to run this like a giant evaluation
in terms of all the social tasks or
social context we can think of and
apparently we want to make a comparison
here so if you look at the blue boxes I
know it's really hard to read the
numbers that's not the goal here we also
have the writer boxes here so the blue
boxes are all the current open source
models we can access many of them are of
very large scale and then the writer
boxes are the open eye models
um we also have this box of fine-tuned
models here many of those numbers are
not only centralized in terms of GT4 and
it turns out that some of the open
source models especially when the output
is short and very concise they can still
do a decent job even in this kind of
zero shot zero shot prompting mode
sure
it's one of these numbers for just to
get a sense of what you mean by this
data is this so like Suppose there is
the row of ideology what does
that number mean or okay yeah
so let's take a humor yeah okay uh if
you look at the line of humor
uh basically we have uh traditional use
the test assets right for a humor the
numbers represent the accuracy or F1
score
yeah
percentage
or no range from 0 to 100.
um if you take the humor here as well in
example so we have let's say standard
tester set to categorize whether
something is a humor or not and then you
can basically calculate how well a model
is doing compared to ground shoes uh
tester set this is how those numbers are
calculated so as you can see if you use
a fine tuner model which will use a
Roberta large here you can get something
like a 73 and then if you use like
flying ul2 which is a very big encoder
decoder kind of model open source that
you can get something like uh 56.8 in
this case if you use gp4 you can get
something like 61.3 and then um for many
of those tasks we still see a difference
in terms of fine tuner models versus
this kind of zero shot prompting
this is a classification so basically
you have a lot of sentences some of them
are humor some of them are not you ask
the models whether they have humor in it
the nature of most of these tasks are
they binary or multiple choice kinds of
tasks or or do they have a more
continuous radiation of quality yeah so
some of those tasks are
for categories and then the space could
range from two to four and some of those
event argumentation as you can see here
extraction task actually has more than
20 labels
okay but I mean uh probably somebody
would might argue that here the ground
truth thing has been done by a certain
set of people and culture can have an
impact on what you regarded for your
yes I'm going to go there foreign
exactly exactly so we are going to so I
I wasn't going to have people looking at
another giant table of numbers that
seems not respectful
um so what I'm going to do is that let's
take those numbers and put it into some
questions we all care about today in
terms of how large language model
Empower individuals and what those
numbers mean
just uh
you know sometimes
averages don't contain much information
what you know information is conveyed by
the outliers so for example if you say
you know is the following uh offensive
well you know maybe that's not that
doesn't give me much information but it
is a look uh do you think this is
a stringy offensive and you you know
people people usually agree on what's
extremely offensive but but if if the
model disagrees then that has a lot of
situation
yes yes so
um many of those tasks they are designed
to kind of capture this uh level of
categories or Spectrum so you can
imagine that if we really want to
differentiate that you can have like a
scale of one to five to rate the degree
of offensiveness Etc and it's true that
for the Very extreme cases model may
have a very confidential prediction but
then somewhere in the middle the
prediction may not be very accurate
so
I guess one of the take away earlier was
or at least from the privilege retrace
that those models seems to do very well
in terms of different tasks and then we
were thinking about something a little
bit different here because we have been
talking about that okay large language
models can replace human in many many
ways and then especially related to
um social context tasks one of the very
challenging thing is that you need to
kind of have those resources to test a
very sophisticated construct
so what do we then did is that now let's
take whatever the best performing model
from my China table and use that as a
data annotator this could be gpd4 this
could be a 25 model
etc etc and then we are going to let it
do The annotation for us and then
calculate what would be the agreement
between human and large language model
and then compare that to what what would
be the agreement between a human and
human here
so as you can see on this page where I
just take a few numbers for address
level tasks like emotion stance
misinformation the F1 score is what we
can get from the best performing model
and then if you look at the agreement
here in terms of annotation agreement
utilizing large language model as a data
annotator we seem to get a really good
performance in terms of the classic
Kappa here
so something around 0.6 which is good
and this is even better compared to when
we use average human for human human
annotation agreement
would you extend more why
everyone is low maybe some things are
not as hot
fun decisions and all models
artificial sample
yeah so that's that's a that's a good
Insider so one of the things is that uh
this is the page with the really good
annotation let me finish the next two
page then we take together to answer a
question so if you see this kind of
trend
um for the task I just mentioned like
emotion stance which are widely existed
in many of our current exploration which
we may have a lot of data because
pre-training covers a lot of political
or other kinds of domains when it comes
to tasks like ideology detection
semantic change humor power relations we
see that the agreements tend to drop to
like Fair here
and then for very
um kind of subtle task as some of the
question was asking like implicit hate
speech detection or toxicity prediction
or persuasion detection we see that the
agreements tend to drop significantly
between human and large language models
while the human human agreement is a
little bit hard
so what humans are they like are they
careful workers or careless workers are
they like actually disagreeing or
they're just careless yeah so we because
we cover like more than 30 tasks here
it's really harder for us to do The
annotation for each so right now the
human human annotation agreement
actually come from the original paper
when the author offered this data cited
to the public they need to do this kind
of annotation check to make sure the
data is
quantify something reliable so the
numbers actually are taken from those
papers you can imagine those as I guess
at least experts or people who are
trained to be well qualified for the
task
um also I want you to kind of pay
attention to this so this is like on
dialect we can see that it's actually
extremely low in terms of uh performance
so one thing we have been thinking about
is that if we cannot simply let gpd4
being the annotator here is there a more
kind of collaborative framework we can
introduce so one thing we are exploring
right now is in terms of this
um human AI collaboration framework
where is it possible that we can design
some mechanisms to estimate the
expertise of those large language models
so this could be done by existing
methods such as self-evaluation ask gptn
to judge whether a response from the
previous version is a good annotation or
you could create many many kind of
different prompts to qualify the same
construct and then measure the
uncertainty there as a way to judge the
expertise there
and this could also lead to some sort of
um changed in terms of how we think
about the work allocation when we have a
task where we have certain budget for
annotation or accuracy we have different
type of data points we want to annotate
because functional models may still give
us the best number when it comes to the
task and then how would we assign this
kind of data adaptation to large
language models and to humans and how we
could actually taking it all together as
organization problem
um so can you ask a question so
we speak louder sorry
could be natural for your large language
model to Output probability uh instead
of just a decision zero one
um so in our case uh you mean raise
regard to expertise
um explanation right yeah with respect
to all the quite you know
listed in the previous slides so so
instead of saying what percentage
should give me like copy this score or
like a more like a probability
associated with it for some of those
models we actually can for some of those
we just can get a response so basically
we frame each of the choices as
something like a multiple choice
questions and then let the models pick
uh which type of thing with regard to
the confidence here so some of those you
can actually frame the confidence as a
further question to those large language
models so basically ask them to
self-evaluate like from a confidence
level one to ten how would you rate your
confidence to the current question
okay
um I'm probably going to skip this kind
of like a skidding law but basically we
observe something very interesting and a
lot of those I don't have great answers
so apparently for the flan T5 family
models we see that as a model parameters
increase they tend to do better in terms
of those social understanding tasks and
the way it comes to um
this is from other to text adventure001
we also see this kind of like skating to
some extent however for this kind of
social understanding task we actually
didn't observe this kind of jump in
terms of a perfect skinning lock here
and in fact there's even a job in terms
of gpt4 performance yeah
I missed in the previous ly so these the
harder tasks is there also higher human
to human disagreement as well
lead track we have human agreements for
some of those so for this page as you
can see implicit head speech detection
so this is a task that we have a lot of
hateful content but they do not ex
involve explicit swear words etc etc so
the the hatred is actually latent and
then for human human you can have
something like 0.55 in terms of uh
flights de Kappa here but then in terms
of large language model and human they
can only achieve 0.19 no I guess what
I'm saying is that
here the the the
models are not doing very well yes yes
and previously are the human to human
agreements also worse than before no
it's comparable
yeah so there seems to be I think there
was one of the earlier question when the
task gets very subjective and require a
lot of contacts or even background you
see that uh although human a human can
agree very well with each other human
and a model cannot achieve something
plausible here but if that's the
subjective why don't you see human to
human disagreement
um that's a good question I think in
many of those annotations you actually
do not uh just like take a sentence out
of nowhere to give it to annotators you
wanted to have a very in-depth
understanding what's going on so in
general when we give annotators The
annotation we give them a context so
they kind of understand that or if I see
like implicit hate I want to kind of
understand the hit speech related to
election you're probably going to have
people who are familiar with U.S culture
to do it rather than someone who will
come from a different background but the
the model doesn't get that context the
model currently does not get that
contact that sounds unfair to the for a
model yeah we need a better prompting
yes
totally non-human question so
I'm talking about these scaling laws but
one is kind of notoriously trained or
just a stupid amount of tasks uh huge
expensive like there are these types
similar they destroying how they like
compare yeah
um I actually put it as a limitation in
my slides so you are right like in the
training offline there are actually an
amazing amount of tasks and some of them
actually do have overlap with what we
are testing here so there is definitely
like a leakage issue here but when we
think about like a social context or a
social understanding capability
environment
um
we try to gather more and more kind of
non-overlapping pascals so maybe a
better thing we should plot here is that
you stand up the overall performance we
should put those like an overlapping
tasks
I guess maybe what I'm trying to
understand is is your claim here that as
it gets more model parameters in the
general way
where that is better at remembering
yeah so so two two levels first level is
that if I just look at this figure
basically what I mean is that the
Forefront type of models when their
scale gets larger they tend to be better
at a social understanding task the level
two is that in order to better provide
explanation here we really need to
understand other kind of like leakage
issue here that this part I don't have a
greater way to quantify this movement
uh that's what
Okay so a lot of questions and I think
that this is also something very tricky
when we think about when we deploy those
models to kind of do a lot of real world
tasks because if we think about
constructs like humor or politeness or a
lot of those constructs it's actually
very subtle and require expert
taxonomies maybe we need a contacts
maybe we need like a better assumption
uh statement and also the size of the
target label space is kind of in euro
compared to most of the tasks we are
dealing with and also a lot of like
temporal grounding in terms of knowledge
which seems a limitation here and uh for
many of those I want to share it as
overall
um pattern as we are still working on it
and there are a lot of issues we cannot
tease out in this process such as the
leakage issue and also a lot of the
causality of whether this is a real kind
of reflection of what's Happening
but this fact that I think there are
still kind of insights we can kind of uh
take a take as a takeaway so there is
this kind of new paradigm which is very
exciting I didn't go into the detail of
how human the AI can collaborate to do
annotation together but this apparently
seems to be a new paradigm of how we
should think about a lot of and Euro
tasks and how we should approach them
and this also opens something around the
simulation which I'm going to talk about
next
so the second part is I want to switch a
little bit since it's about people and
the English right now seems to be the
main language we are communicating with
large language models however if we kind
of read
um a lot of the content outside and also
pay attention to a lot of the Research
In fairness though
um currently current large current
language technology seems to struggle
when it comes to um dialects or language
that are not spoken by the mainstream
population
and we kind of mentioned this in some of
the earlier work when
um talking about the pre-training ETC
apparently a lot of the English dialect
data actually get filtered out from the
pre-trunee as low quality based on their
publicity and this is one of the uh
triggering for why those models probably
cannot work well the other thing is that
because English dialects and the
Standard Market English are so similar
when you simply combine them together
they might harm performance because some
of the dialect features are probably
going to be washed out by the large
amount of standard American English we
have
we have a lot of empirical studies in
terms of is this a real issue and is
this a real issue for large language
models on the right you can see that
when you plot the relationship between
model size and their ability to
recognize data to Features you can see
that those numbers are actually not as
impressive as we can imagine
F1 score usually is something around 20
even with ul2 we can get something like
50 but that's still not enough if we
really want to use it in a context to
see is this a dialogue should we treat
it differently Etc
so my group has been building efforts in
terms of how we can actually teach those
models to understand a lot of the low
resource dialects here and we call it a
multi-value effort with this kind of
resources you can actually do that as
stress test you can take any existing
NLP systems and protube the data to see
whether it works for a low resource
dialect
um we actually look at a lot of English
dialects here there are 77 of them so
what I'm showing you is only five of
them so we cover African-American
English Chicano English Indian English
approaching English and also Singapore
English here
the process of how we build it is
actually quite
um straightforward so we take our
linguistic literature and try to First
do this kind of synthetic transformation
where we are going to translate a lot of
the well-known features for dialysis so
that they we can convert a standard
American English sentence into a
specific dialect like Ave here
um this is a very well known feature
associated with black English so if you
think about she don't have a camera this
will become she doesn't have a camera it
will become she don't have no camera in
Ave as you can imagine this is actually
going to cause issues to models in terms
of how to deal with negation
um after the first stage we actually
work with native speakers that we
recruit from all over the US to kind of
validate and rewrite it into something
that's uh both linguistically profound
and also socially uh accessible
you may Wonder like does it really
matter well if you look at this figure
take a very simple model like Roberta
and take a very simple task sort of not
ambiguous task here like sentiment we
saw that the performance job from
94.6 to 92.4
um this kind of job is consistent if you
look at a lot of the tasks we have
access to or we did a perturbation and
apparently for tasks like question
answering when there are a lot of like
spoken questions we saw that the
performance is even bigger
if you simply just fine tune with a lot
of those type of data the disparity
Still Remains
this is just unlike African-American
English if you think about Indian
English or Singapore English or
Appliance English there are two
different degree of job in terms of
performance on something that we can
clean we solve the task like
conversational question answering
um a lot of the cool work of these days
has been built in terms of how we can
actually do efficient adaptation of
large language models to more englishes
so
um hopefully the two that we are
building around the value can actually
help develop this kind of type of
dialect adaptation so this is building
up how many of the efficient defined
tuning work that the Cody and the Shasha
mentioned earlier
uh the key idea is that you can actually
use a very small amount of parameters to
learn something specific to the task and
also learn something specific to the
dialect and use them in a plug and play
way for a better adaptation
um just to give you a little bit
highlight of the performance so this is
what we showed earlier in terms of
sentiment analysis if you only design
this kind of adaptation with 0.04
percentage of tunable parameters you can
actually mitigate the Gap well for some
task
and such mitigation is also consistent
for a lot of other applications here
uh just to quickly summarize this so I
think here for when people think about
dialect or low resource languages
um a lot of times there may be like
speech factors or excellent factors that
involve So currently our work does not
cover the speech aspect and then also
since a lot of the work are rooted in
linguistics we don't cover uh like more
recent Lux conversations or undocumented
the variations here
I guess before I move to the third part
are there questions
asked originally in standard American
English
language has changed do you think that
in the real world across the different
dialects you actually have a
distribution shift of the
types of
yes that's that's true so there are a
few considerations here first is that
when you when we want to kind of justify
there is a language disparity the first
step we want to make sure is that for
Samsung we have in common or we have
studied a lot to see what's the
correspondence performance there if we
switch the language so that's the one of
the design choice of why we go with this
so that you can see the number on
Standard Market English and on other low
resource language so that's one of the
design choices and you are right like in
fact in the process of working with
people we actually uh have a
procedure called the password design
approach where even during the very
beginning we actually sit down with
native speakers to see how we actually
can do this research in a more
responsible way they talk about that we
don't use our dialogue to read the New
York Times in this way because maybe
some of our data sets has near Times
articles uh you also get to know a lot
of like nuanced insights here like okay
this this usage is probably from last
century and now we are doing some other
different cool terms or cool like uh
more for syntax etc etc and then there
will be uh generational differences
there will be original differences a lot
of those so the space is actually huge
what I want to emphasize here is that if
we just take a share the task and we can
see the disparity clearly hopefully
there will be more and more people
working on this problem
thank you
okay uh finally I I want to talk about
something very exciting and hopefully we
can switch to a little bit a different
mode in terms of uh social and people
and also how large language models can
play a role here
that's very exciting
um so this is actually not a something
new
um
starting from last year because of the
impressive capabilities of those models
this factor that they may struggle with
a lot of the subjective or nuanced or
social understanding you can actually
use them for a lot of like cool
applications for example uh one work
from Adam actually uh use large language
models to simulate uh humans and as a
way to explore whether we can replicate
a human subject studies
there are also work that I try to build
a village with different large language
model powered agents so that they can
interact with each other for very cool
applications so a lot of work
and then in fact this is definitely
related to human right like large
language models stimulating humans and
it's uh there because a lot of Greater
benefits we can achieve from this
process first it's going to reduce your
cost because you do not need to probably
uh recruit a lot of people in order to
test the product
you can pre-validate the study you can
customize your participants
um
for a lot of counterfactual aspects you
probably can reduce adding concerns
the issue might be evaluation is really
hard adaptation is really hard
representation is very hard so I want
you to keep all of those in mind in
terms of thinking about when we
simulating humans or even use them for
different type of Agents what would be
the issues here
so what I'm going to talk about is that
because we see a lot of the cool
applications you can perform on top of
large language models you can actually
create a simulate environment with
different role there powered by large
language model so that they can help
human to do something here
we call this social skill training and
then in most cases we are going to have
two agents one is what we call an AR
partner that basically representing you
digitized users who you can practice
with for different topics there will
also be AI Mentor this is another large
language model empowered Mentor who can
provide feedback to help people improve
their skills
so turning it into something
more straightforward let's see I want to
learn negotiation I want to learn how to
think positively
um
then I'm going to practice with this AI
partner in a simulated environment
and in the process I also want to
receive feedback so there may be another
expert AI Mentor we can build to kind of
mediate this process or help me learn
this process so think about you have a
coach who's sitting with you for you to
kind of practice your conversations
and this kind of social skill training
can be very generic again this is work
in progress so I welcome all sorts of
feedback but highly
um this is the process of how we
approach it we first sort of like
designed AI partner for people in those
high risk conversations and then we are
going to operationalize expert knowledge
into computable strategies and then we
are going to create a AI Mentor by all
sorts of conditional generation planning
contacts memory Etc
last step is that we are going to
integrate them into a single little
environment for users to learn safely so
what does that what does that mean
um if we put it into different contexts
here uh think about therapy mental
health is such a big issue we don't have
enough therapists there are a lot of
people who want to learn how to be good
supporters to each other so the user
here is Noble's counselor who want to
learn or enhance their therapy skills
and then the partner here is going to be
a digitalized patient and then the
mentor here is going to be a therapy
coach
um or if you think about confident
resolution there will be people who want
to handle different conversations and
then the partner is going to be
digitalized partner and then a coach
will be confident resolution experts so
you can also design similar situations
for education and negotiation yes
I have a question which is
I mean this is a setting which could
also apply to any other tutoring setting
right like teaching students how to
solve physics problems
so uh can you say and wouldn't can you
say what you think are the special
reasons you prefer this domain versus
teaching physics or biology or whatever
because this has some additional
complications
right
yeah yeah exactly so
um I think that's a great extension of
how we can actually further leverage
this uh framework the way how we uh or
how I picked the student is that
um first this is something I'm super
excited I think the like social skills
social intelligence are something that
we wanted models to help people with and
also a lot of those skills are actually
not something you can easily learn in
real world think about
um negotiation or conflict resolution
you actually take courses or MBA classes
or a lot of those and those are not
available for people who probably cannot
afford it and then so part of the
choices for what we focus on here is we
really want to kind of make a skill
training a lot of the key skill training
accessible to everyone
so that was one of my design choices but
with regard to teaching physics or
teaching like other subjects I think
that you will need a very wrong data
Knowledge from that German to sort of
help run it otherwise it may be a little
bit of challenge here we also need a
grounding but because of the very
expressive nature of those large
language models you can actually do a
relative good job in terms of practicing
those Corner cases for people
um so in previous studies there have
been
um different results that there are
little different biases embedded in
and like let's say you have a woman
negotiating the work and then the model
has embed advice it's how would you deal
with this case yeah that's an excellent
question so uh the way how we approach
them is so the system I'm going to show
you later we actually make sure that
let's say you want to practice your
skill in negotiation you have someone in
mind you are going to customize what
would be the specific role you are going
to interact with so we give users full
control in terms of the explicit
attributes you want to practice maybe a
female feel less empowered in those
positions so they really want to
practice with a senior colleague uh
etc etc so you can actually customize it
in the interface then the digitalized
patient or HR or partner will be
switched to a different Persona so in
this way we make sure that you can
actually practice forces that you do not
feel safe to do impact in real world
um yeah so I wanted to mention a
different uh bias which is that uh
people often kind of treat solutions
that come from
kind of like more correct or sort of
like uh more trusted and so I'm
wondering if it's a situation like
conflict resolution uh this could create
problems where you're like oh okay like
I said the things that the system told
me I should say and the other person got
mad at me anyways it must be their fault
that I don't have to worry about it uh
response as opposed to them being like
more willing to
be good yeah this is also an excellent
question so but I think this is not the
first time you face this if you think
about like coaching centers or a lot of
the educational centers you'll learn
specific skill there there is no
guaranteeing that uh the scenarios you
are going to see in real world will
replicate what you have been taught in
school right so in this case I I guess
what I mean is that there is going to be
a distribution or shift potentially in
terms of what you are practicing here in
terms of what you are going to do in
real world right now the the practice
the best practice we take is that you
make every of those
um kind of potential issues explicit to
users so when they practice with the
system they know that this is not going
to be representing the outside world
they need to use this in a more
contextual way but the system is
designed in a way to teach them how to
learn those kids skills so it's not
actually about the exact wording you are
going to learn uh in terms of conflict
resolution we actually take this
um literature from business school in
terms of power interest uh framework so
you're actually learning strategies not
specific wording well I guess what I'm
imagining is because the model is
queryable people might use it also in
their specific situation right they like
oh imagine this hypothetical situation
what should I do but actually it is like
the actual situation they're dealing
with and they're just direct negative
advice
the model or do you think like uh for
some reason that couldn't happen
yeah I think that that thing can
definitely happen so uh in that case I
wouldn't wish that the user when they
use the system they kind of customize
the digitalize the pattern in a very
specific way so that to kind of minimize
the potential shift in terms of all
sorts of scenarios so yeah
[Music]
yes yes that's what I'm going to show
um yeah I mean just your time let's give
um let's just skip
um
so the current system we build is that
you actually let's see Alex is someone
who want to learn this kind of support
skills and then without this type of
system today Alex misses something
really bad like just sounds really bad
the two are very overwhelming sentence
and then with this type of systems we
are going to build uh Alex May respond
in a very supportive way and then in
this process you will have like kind of
two uh agents we introduced here Jane is
actually going to be a AI partner and
then um uh the care system here which is
our AI Mentor because of the sensitive
nature we actually need to fine-tune a
gpt2 model to this very specific mental
health therapy domain so we have this
offline model in terms of providing
feedback
um this is what it being deployed in the
system so as you can see uh the blue
boxes are actually from the person who
want to practice and then the member is
actually this kind of uh patient who
have issues for any of those scenarios
you are going to recommend the potential
uh strategy this person is going to take
and this user can actually take up any
of those messages and then further
editing them to form their response and
a lot of the log analysis since we kind
of keep track of how people interact
with the system it actually help around
the 84 percentage of the time if your
Deep dive into what they like what it
doesn't like people like the fact that
they remind them of strategies is by a
response increase confidence they don't
like the fact that it may disrupt
thinking or may limit the response or
take time to read
um again we do a lot of this kind of
like very um in-depth interview with
participants when they use the system I
some of them mention that this is a
great tool for listeners who are new or
who are not feeling comfortable with the
topic
um I also want to just quickly show this
type of thing since the earlier version
is actually with GT2
um in fact you can actually do this with
this kind of gp4 and you have much more
powerful results
um the way how we teach is that we are
building this mixed initiative agent in
framework where we want people to
practice uh difficult conversations and
how to learn a mess learn how to handle
those difficult conversations
I'm going to skip the details here but
with this kind of system compared to
current tuning materials or the current
training fashion individuals who
actually learn through our kind of
Market agent systems are actually 40
percentage less likely to use aggressive
strategies three times more likely to
proactively propose solutions to deal
with conflicts
um this is basically what I want to
cover today so I really hope that I at
least the comments at least one of you
that social understanding is actually
very challenging for models at this
point and then there are a lot of
objectives or questions we couldn't
think about beyond what has been focused
today and just to kind of take it back
um there are lots of issues related to
people such as culture value Norm
fairness privacy trust and impact and I
hope that there will be more and more
exciting research in the space of human
AI interaction thank you
so like some of the strategies that you
are coming up with to do you
cross-reference that with your training
Corpus to see that if it is derived from
like valid sources or kind of combined
from multiple sources I'm kind of going
into more like a topic modeling but
these are pretty critical decisions
right sorry you are referring to the
skill training or the first one like the
way we were kind of giving the
strategies right they are grounded in
literature so for example the therapy
skills we actually work with a
psychiatrists to leverage framework like
motivational interviewing strategies
which is a framework of how like
therapies are trained so basically
operationalize all the possible
strategies there into a specific like
something like a dialogue act and then
we basically teach people in terms of
specific strategies similarly with
conflict resolution there are expert
taxonomy you can leverage from business
contacts and then basically we teach
those Concepts to people yeah so do you
also see like multiple strategies that
combine in an hallucination uh setting
like do you see kind of this kind of
things and how do you protect or how I
mean is there some sort of metric that
you are looking to figure these out yeah
so that's a great question so right now
in the current process of planning at
each step
only focus down
which means that we are going to
generate all possible
sentences that each sentence contains
one strategy so although you can also
cover all strategies in one sentence but
you actually can have a lot of choices
so user can actually explore which one
to use and then have more contextual
reactions
yeah so I have a question regarding to
evaluation of this
this skill training for these people it
seems like currently the evaluation is
based on after taking the social skill
training from the large language model
you ask them like how happy you are with
the training and some kind of mini test
then like it doesn't necessarily reflect
whether that people is actually going to
be
skillful when they do it at practice so
I wonder what do you think about that
evaluation and especially like the
evaluation the effect of that training
will not be immediately available
address
yes excellent question so uh evaluation
uh at the several level so today I think
I basically skip the offline Corpus
evaluation that's the standard
evaluation we do like basically let's
see if you have a coppers how well you
can identify strategies we focus on the
level two that is at this like user
exploration stage how well that works in
this kind of lab study environment we
have stage three that is more long-term
evaluation and that takes a long time as
you can imagine for example for
therapists who use these systems we
actually
um have access to like patients who
interact with them so we're going to
quantify their self-efficacy or
confidence throughout the next three or
six months we're also going to quantify
like for people who are willing to
interact with people who use these
systems do their mental health change
Etc so there are actually different
levels we're also going to open this up
for students in like uh
um Psychiatry and also business school
to kind of try these systems in their
classroom teaching to see how well it
compared to what you use today like
textbook or a lot of other uh devices
yeah that sounds super exciting thank
you uh last question over there
um another question that I had thank you
for a great content
um so for the first task that you
mentioned about annotation a lot of
these models are not the stable and like
they're changing all the time and there
is no reproducibility basically with
these models how do you deal with that
when you are using these models for
annotation and then human evaluation
yes so uh yes models are changing and
the results are changing so I think we
are in this like a very interesting
stage that everyone is chasing the bar
of large language models to do something
uh I think right now the the practice we
take is that you still sort of have the
best performing model at a given
timestamp right so you go with that and
stability is a key issue uh very
interestingly I think the recent models
are kind of getting stable in terms of
how you do different prompting and then
temperature effects but not to a great
extent and then we do have different
ways of like quantify their uncertainty
when it comes to an insta us let's say
even with slighted um perturbation to
The Prompt or to the environments the
models decision change dramatically then
that's probably not a best use case for
model to do annotation you need to kind
of defer it to humans so you can
actually quantify this kind of and
stability or expertise to some extent
thank you
[Applause]
and since we don't have time for a break
and everybody just stand up and stretch
so we owe the next feature also on
ascensions
please don't
know